[Music]
joining me today is the Milbank Family
Center senior fellow at the Hoover
Institution at Stanford University a
senior fellow at the Center for European
studies at Harvard where he also served
as a professor of history for 12 years
as well as the author of 14 books Neil
Ferguson
welcome to the Reuben report it's
exciting to be here how'd I do on the
intro there I mean I was looking through
your bio 14 books there were 87 other
things I could have credited you for
we've already done an interview here in
just the 15 minutes we've been sitting
here how it was that all right I mean I
could have just yelled like the results
of the bet sir is my feeling about
introductions now justice said he is
Neil but here's Neil all right there's a
ton we got a cover here and we've
already done half of it I think without
the cameras so let's just dive in
immediately to the culture war stuff
because I can tell you've been traveling
a lot half jet-lagged half wide awake
but I can see that's really where your
head's at at the moment so let's talk
some culture war stuff what do you feel
is happening sort of in the gestalt of
the universe at the moment well you
started the university might be where we
should begins as I've spent a lot of my
life in universities you mentioned a
couple of them they're Stanford and
Harvard I was at Oxford before that and
much of my life has been I think
witnessing the gradual homogenization of
academic life especially in the field
like history when I became a historian
back in the 1980s in Oxford and then in
Cambridge it was generally accepted that
there could be conservative historians
and liberal historians and socialist
historians and then some moxie stories
it was really quite a heterogeneous
community Oxbridge in those days and if
you were as I was attracted to the
Conservatives because they were more fun
it was more right but more fun the fun
was the initially attractive thing when
I first got to Oxford in the early 80s
it was clearly the funniest people were
the Thatcher IDEs
the young Andrew Sullivan who was a year
ahead of me at maudlin so this was all
great fun yeah and it led to into
show insight because they turned out
also to be right the historians take Bob
Conquest who was then at the Hoover
Institution one of the few historians
who got the Soviet Union right at the
time who wrote about Stalin's crimes not
long after they were perpetrated I mean
those were the heroes of my early years
but in the course of my career what has
happened has been that one history
department after another has moved
steadily and relentlessly to the
monochrome left and it has become
steadily harder to to be seen as a
conservative I say seen as because I've
never really felt that I'm a
conservative but I've often been
described as one yeah to be seen as a
conservative historian has become
steadily harder and harder and as a
result the culture war to use your
phrase in the Universities has been won
by the left there will really be soon a
handful left of conservatives at
institutions like Harvard and Stanford
and Harvey Mansfield will probably be
the last one at Harvard and and that's
to me deeply depressing deeply troubling
do you remember a moment when you saw
that shift occurring because you're
saying in the in the 80s mid eighties it
was pretty diverse in terms of ideas do
you remember seeing something or did you
see markers that started that you could
start putting together the map of where
this thing was gonna go I think the
definition of defeat in the culture war
is that it's imperceptible you're aware
of it a little bit each year because in
a typical department each year somebody
retires or dies but they're always
replaced with somebody working on let's
say for the sake of argument gender
history so you your colleague was was
lecturing on the history of the Soviet
Union Richard pipes who was at Harvard
and and just lately died one of the
great historians of the Bolshevik
Revolution
you don't ever see someone like that
replaced with somebody like him there'll
always be replaced by somebody working
on gender history Native American
history that that process whereby there
was no replacement of conservative
historians was a more or less annual
event I got accustomed to being in a
real minority a minority of conservative
historians I got accustomed to losing
pretty much every vote being in the
minority on every committee it became a
kind of you you got a climatized to it
and then one day suddenly hit you that
you were practically the last one left
and you know when I moved to Stanford
the revelation was quite startling I was
invited to come to the Hoover
Institution many Hoover fellows have
associations joint appointments with
Stanford departments I had been pretty
successful as a teacher at Harvard my
classes had been very large the students
gave me very powerful evaluations I kind
of assumed that I would come to Stanford
and have some relationship with the
history department and then I was told
oh no no none at all not even a courtesy
appointment and it was clear at that
moment that I had become in the eyes of
the Stanford history department a pariah
somebody who who simply couldn't be
allowed in the building
because of my my conservative leanings
can you explain a little bit more about
how the universities work like that that
that could even happen they're gonna
they're gonna bring you in you're a
fellow there and that you're just gonna
be ignored by the department that you're
an expert in you know it's quite
insulting especially as you mentioned as
I've published rather lots of books
yeah fact rather more than then most of
the department put together and I think
a department with falling enrollments
might have been expected to to want to
have me playing a part but what happened
and it's happened in most departments in
most universities inexorably the left
took over and an implicit rule a tacit
rule was imposed that one does not hire
right-leaning
historians nor does one hire their
graduate students so they to people who
have been my graduate students have
found it difficult to get hired so it's
essentially a straightforward a process
whereby the institution is taken over
one committee at a time and the left has
been good at that for the better part of
a century they've always had how do you
think they saw that how did they have
the foresight to go all right we've got
to take over the universities first I
think that on the right the previous
generation of historians and this was
also true of philosophers and people
working in other fields did not fight
very hard or effectively to promote
their successors in academic life you
need to be mindful of the succession the
left was better at ensuring that it's
protegees got the appointments
ultimately academia is a committees game
it's all about getting to be the chair
of the department to be in charge of the
committee's if you control the process
you control the selection you control
the recruitment and I suppose I'm I'm
such a naive person I kind of in my
youth assumed we were in a broadly
meritocratic world in which if you were
smart and hard-working
then then good things would would happen
and it took me all that yeah I was
completely Knight it took me a while to
cotton on to the fact that in in reality
in academic life as another walks of
life patronage is everything and you can
be as talented as you like if you're not
in the right patronage Network then
you're done and I suppose it's been
thinking about these issues how do
networks capture institutions the that
led me to write that the most recent
book the square on the tower was
actually book number 15 yeah
to try to think about how networks
operate we tend to talk casually about
networks but I came to realize that in
academic life as in other areas you need
to understand quite exactly quite
precisely how networks operate to see
how power is truly wielded we can all
see the hierarchical institutions that
are where power is located right even
universities are clearly not as powerful
as as government's but the critical
point is to understand the disease often
networks that capture institutions that
capture the hierarchies and that's what
happens in academic life and now I think
pretty soon there just won't be
conservatives in university departments
more importantly than that nobody will
be teaching subjects like the history of
the Soviet Union so no students will be
taught about the crimes of Lenin and
Stalin and students like the students I
taught yesterday will not hear from
anybody that there was a religious
motivation to the 9/11 attacks I had a
class at Stanford yesterday I was
allowed to sit in and teach somebody
else's class as a guest professor and it
happened to be a discussion about 9/11
and it became clear to me that the
students had never considered the
possibility that there was religious
motivation to the 9/11 attacks and more
or less except the idea that they were
retaliation for the misdeeds of u.s.
foreign policy in the Middle East what
are called the Howard Zinn theory and
since Howard Zinn's books are more
widely read in the United States than
anybody else's history books we
therefore arrive at a situation in which
there will be nobody in any major
universities saying actually Howard Zinn
is completely wrong and this is not what
9/11 was about so that's what I find
depressing when I say that the culture
was kind of over and the universities
that's really what I mean yeah so let's
circle back because it does bring us to
your 15th book I stand
did decide this idea of networks because
we were talking right before we started
that there's something happening here
with this loose Association of people
that has been coined the intellectual
dark web and I said to you and you
walked in are you part of the
intellectual dark web as if you were
gonna give me a secret handshake or a
special card or when I was asked about
it I denied all knowledge didn't the
assumption that it was secret and then
it turned out to be all over the New
York Times yeah but are you worried you
weren't photographed in the bushes like
the rest of us but I suspect that you
secretly are in the intellectual dark
web well I couldn't possibly reveal that
because it's secret but but you said
something interesting about because of
your level of academic credit that you
thought perhaps that took you out of it
but then christina hoff sommers said
something interesting yeah what Barry
Weiss emailed me and my wife ayaan Hirsi
Ali who's been on your show is
interesting than me is the greatest I
mean we she now let's be tough for you
because millions of people love your
work and everything else but it's like
ion is like transcended she's wonderful
it's the most enormous wonderful
blessing in my life to be married to
somebody who's just way more interesting
than me thank you too so that so we were
both asked by Barry Weiss about the
intellectual dark web and I said look
how can I really claim to be part of
that when I taught for 12 years at
Harvard left of my own volition I'm here
at Stanford can write newspaper columns
and have them published more or less
where I want it would it would be a
little disingenuous to claim kinship
with people like Brett Weinstein who've
been persecuted by the academic left
that I've been attacked I've been
criticized but I haven't really been
driven underground at least not at this
point but Christina Summers said to me
just the other night no it's not about
whether you've been denied a platform or
not clearly almost all the people in the
article that Barry wrote of have plenty
of opportunities to make their views
known it's about whether you are seen to
speak
for people who feel that they have been
silenced who feel that their voices
aren't heard right that's quite a good
definition of what this is about
but you're also right to see that it's a
network as I was reading the article I
was thinking have funny I know all these
people the sole exception of Jordan
Peters no I've never met I sense that's
coming well yeah I hope so I look
forward to it
but I think it's a network of the most
ideal sort it is a truly informal
network of people from right across the
political spectrum because nobody could
call Brett Weinstein a conservative yeah
who have come together spontaneously
informally nobody called it into being
and said I'm forming the intellectual
dark web turn up on Monday at 5:00 p.m.
right and I does it change does it
change the second its name generally a
network so if this is the right type of
network right it's cool kind of diverse
group of people who had all sorts of
different motivations and everything
else once it's sort of named does that
change the way a network has to operate
because I sense that's what the
discussion is about right now yeah
although not I think fundamentally that
the critical thing is when something
ceases to be secret I tell the story of
the Illuminati a network in the late
18th century in Germany that sought to
advance a radical version of the
Enlightenment but covertly as a secret
organization the intellectual dark web
I semi seriously said was was secret
until Barry wrote that right right and
and now that it's out in the in the open
what will happen is that it will grow
because people Andrew Sullivan I was
discussing it with him to said why am I
in it and of course the answer is but
you should be really I mean anybody who
who is engaged in critical thinking
about the whole range of ideas in our
society ranging from the political to
the social and cultural anybody who is
in the debate and is antagonistic to the
dogmas of the left the political
correctness the identity politics the
spurious pursuit of so-called social
justice
if you are skeptical if you are thinking
critically about the dogmas of the left
then you belong in the intellectual dark
web because you're the kind of person
who at some point will be no platformed
who at some point will be taken down who
at some point will be the target of a
hit piece in the new york times one of
the characteristic features of the
intellectual dark web I think is that
most members at one time or another have
fallen foul of the leftist thought
police and as soon as you've had that
experience it's happened to me a number
of times but that is quite
transformative yeah I mean it literally
changed my life it's the only reason
you're sitting here right now I was once
one of them and and I suspect your
experience was like mine you'll kind of
taken aback to be on the receiving end
of a social media mob you're kind of
taken aback to be attacked not for the
substance of anything that you've argued
or written or said you're attacked for
your reputation you're attacked for your
alleged bad faith and each time this has
happened to me I've I've been a little
stunned I was naive
not only was I a believer in meritocracy
I was also a believer that we were
engaged in a rational debate about the
past that's what historians do and that
one made one's case presented the
evidence and then the other side did the
same but I wrote a book a book about the
British Empire know what 15 or so years
ago an argument that their argument of
that book was that not everything about
the British Empire was bad there were
benefits as well as costs to imperialism
and I never had a debate about that
argument
I only ever was attacked by the left for
being an apologist of empire and
neo-colonialist etc and so in that
curious debate that that is central to
the culture war you never really are
engaged with on the ideas all the
evidence it is always about
whether you have bad faith or not
whether you are covertly
yeah racists an Islamophobe are
homophobe that there's a long list of
things that you can be accused of but
those are the most popular ones ones
never really discussing the arguments of
the books ones always discussing the
personality of the author yeah so this
is just sort of simply put the ideas
first people conversation right so in in
a case of vayan I mean to live through
the things that she has lived through
between FGM and her and her and her
friend being murdered and the whole
thing to be called the things that she's
called I mean it flips your very
personhood on its head
which is I mean it's it's so deeply
twisted the episode that for me brought
it into bold relief was the the Brandeis
honorary degree Fiasco when I on was
invited by the president of Brandeis and
this was in 2014 yeah except an honorary
degree in speaker commencement and then
was very publicly and humiliatingly
disinvited under pressure from an unholy
alliance as far as I could see of
leftists and Islamists who set out
online to smear her reputation with the
usual confection of selective quotation
and and misrepresentation and as often
happens in these situations the
university authorities capitulate
without a fight to the left and and they
do it publicly and that that for me was
a that was a moment when I learnt a lot
about what was going wrong in American
academic life and realized that it's
it's the combination of of aggressive
activists on the left and useful idiots
in university bureaucracies so is it
fold is it that they're useful idiots or
is it just is it just sort of blanket
cowardice by on part of some of the
academics but really the the
administrators and the upper brass at
all the schools and the fact that the
donors although this is changing right
now and as we're taping this today I
know it's going to be out in a couple
days
evergreen is now firing a whole bunch of
professors which is exactly whatever it
what all of us predicted basically
because the donors have just had enough
it's fascinating so it's hard like where
it is just cowardice cowardice is the
most powerful force in human history no
doubt and I'm constantly amazed at just
how much cowardice is out there
my wife's experience has shown me that
the the the the difficulty of getting
people publicly to support her work
against Islamic extremism is all about
cowardice fear of being in any way drawn
into into the the real war the jihad
facing the death threats that she has
repeatedly had to face but it's not just
cavitus and there's a good deal of
complicity many university
administrators are themselves
ideologically on the left and feel that
they have a mission to empower the the
leftists in the student body and this is
I think a different thing from from
cowardice so yeah I think I think this
is a fascinating moment in time because
donors alumni look at what is going on
on university campuses as do people who
have not had the privilege of university
education who see it all as complete
madness and ask the question what the
hell is going on here and I think the
more that question gets asked the better
but we should not underestimate the
massive inertia in the system it is
extremely hard even if you're a
university president you say right I'm
going to clean house it's really hard to
do because they're all tenured I mean
the faculty is tenured it happened
everywhere you know to me like we don't
find oh well you know in the Northeast
it's a little bit better that you know
just even geographically we just don't
even see that yes there are bastions of
Serrano my per University of Chicago or
you know like a couple places or a
little bit better but how do you think
it actually spread that way that it
wasn't just here and there and Lehrer
that universities are always left-wing
but that's not true for example if you
had been in Germany in the 1920s the
universe's were bastions of conservatism
an extreme and indeed extreme
when nationalism which is one reason
that universities very quickly went over
to the Nazi regime when Hitler came to
power so it's there's no golden rule
that says universities have to be
left-wing Oxford and Cambridge in the
18th century were extraordinary action
airy fundamentally religious
institutions and deeply Tory with a few
exceptions and they're in their politics
so there's no real rule here I think the
best explanation I can offer you is a
process of generational capture of
education institutions dating from the
1960s universities in let's take the
elite universities the Ivy League
universities in the 1950s were already
seen as being liberal and if you were a
kind of McCarthy leaning Republican you
already knew that Harvard was likely
full of fellow-travellers and covert
commies but the real shift I think came
later I think it came with the anti-war
protests of the late 60s and early 70s
the more radical baby boomers who were
protesting in the campuses in 68 into
the early 70s it grew up to become
professors know still around and I think
that generation which was essentially
formed at the time of the anti-war
protests successfully replicated itself
they were very very good at replicating
themselves by creating graduate students
in their own image and then making sure
that those graduate students got jobs
and and the right was nowhere so you
were you were out there writing books
doing research and figuring well alright
they're doing that and maybe in the long
run and my heroes at Oxford and
Cambridge who wrote great books and were
also politically active people like
Norman stone or Roger Scruton who did
much of the thinking that that
accompanied that tourism in the 1980s
what they did not do well was academic
politics they were poor at that they
were poor at succession planning and
that is I think the best explanation I
can offer for the fact
in nearly all universities in North
America and in Europe 90% plus of
faculty members are liberals or
progressives if not outright Marxists
alright so with some of the historical
context of how this all happened I know
you are enthused about this new network
idea because it's come around the right
way do you think there's a gatekeeping
responsibility for whoever is involved
in this this seems to be one of the hot
button issues with this thing or who can
be in this whatever it is what are the
ideas that cannot be on the inside I see
it
coming much more that we have to watch
out for ideas on the right than on the
left that seems to be the way it's being
framed at least from where I sit how
would you do that in a in a proper
Network mother doing our two kinds of
networks open access networks let's take
the example of Facebook where you can
just join up and open a Facebook account
you can even do it as a fake human being
and then there are the restricted access
networks extreme cases the secret
societies of of the 18th and 19th
century don't really have many analogues
today because it's hard to do anything
secret means secrecy barely exists any
anymore in the age of of WikiLeaks so
you have to I think decide whether to be
an open or closed or restricted access
network and the minute you're a
restricted access network somebody is
making the decisions about who joins
then ends up being the the Membership
Committee and then you're just a club
really yeah I don't think that's an
option in in our time I think an open
access networks the only real way to go
and you must accept that if the if the
intellectual dark web is is real that
it's an open access network that that
won't necessarily connect you to ever
really that you want to be connected to
it may connect you to people that you
positively don't want to be connected to
this has been a central problem I think
of being on the political right for a
long time I can remember in the 1980s
when people said to me well Neil you're
a conservative
and I would say well I'm actually not a
member of the Conservative Party I think
of myself as a classical liberal they
would say oh but nevertheless when I
look at all the things you say right you
were a conservative and then I would
think well does that mean that I have to
have dinner with the likes of and I
think the various egregious conservative
members of parliament right and it was
as if you would be associated with those
people even if you never had dinner with
them and it's the same problem now
except that it's it's worse now because
the way in which the left seeks to
discredit you and Jordan Peterson and
probably me as well now that I'm on your
show I mean 15 you know look at the
people who are connected to these people
oh won't these people or who read their
books they're there they are over there
yeah the terrible alt-right and you know
when you say outright the audience is
supposed to start booing and hissing and
you know Steve Bannon is supposed to
appear in a black robe with the scythe
you know I am deaf so I think that the
problem is I think inescapable there
will be a constant effort on the left to
say that the intellectual dark web is
just some kind of facade in front of an
and a hideous art right which is
composed of remember racists
Islamophobes homophobes
and that will be the culture wars next
right I mean that works we have a
strange amount of gay people and Muslim
people yeah absolutely but there you go
otherwise brown people and every other
type in itself the self-hating phenomena
the letter a long known how to say that
it is absolutely typical of the wicked
right that they should have lured into
their to their side self-hating and then
you just fill in the blank self hating
Muslims self hating gays that's how this
works
remember they lost all the arguments all
they've got left is reputational
smearing man we got a fight in front of
us huh you know I I have lost sleep
about this not only because
people threaten my wife's life that's
the real war that the war against the
Islamic extremists is no is no mere
culture war it's an actual war I've also
lost sleep about the the mere culture
war at the prospect of of the
reputational attacks it's it's never
pleasant to be attacked as I was
recently in effect for being a I guess a
sexist racist or a racist sexist because
I'd organized a conference at which all
the speakers were the white men because
the women I invited couldn't come and
back their lives a private conference
that wasn't supposed to it wasn't it was
a kind of informal discussion about how
we could take the idea of applied
history and make history more relevant
to some of the debates that go on I
think a lot of what has done in academic
history these days is not really
relevant to anything terribly much but
this event was rather crudely exposed in
the New York Times in the Washington
Post the pictures of the speakers were
published as if the the mugshots
as it were appeared in the New York
Times and the implication was that I
must be a terrible racist sexist or
sexist racist for having organized such
a conference I did lose sleep about vas
and I think that part of the the culture
war is really is really odious because
it is it is calculated to discredit the
targeted individuals and it is it's bad
faith on the part of the people who
launched those attacks and where in my
view what's happening with some of those
gated institutions when the newspapers
that used to be objective you know look
Barry wrote this piece in the New York
Times that I think was a pretty fair
piece it was even somewhat critical of
me and I'm not above criticism so I'm
certainly okay with that but then just a
week later we see this awful piece about
Jordan and in Forstmann
and it's just nonsense I mean it's just
nonsense and you know I'm on tour with
him right now and he keeps explaining
why bets of court he doesn't want anyone
to be forced to do anything and all that
he's talking about marriage in effect
yeah and and Eric Weinstein our friend
found two other references in the
history of the New York Times where they
talked about enforced monogamy and they
were both positive relative to
progressive ideals so it's like they
flip everything on its head but what do
you think happened there I mean you've
given me a pretty good layout of what's
happened at the academic side but on the
media side and those those gates what is
going on I spent a lot of my life doing
journalism because I didn't have any
inherited money and being an academic in
Britain in the 1980s and 90s wasn't
terribly lucrative so I kept body and
soul together even from my graduate
years writing for newspapers and
newspapers have had their own
transformation in the course of my adult
life and part of that is just economics
as we all know the business model which
essentially revolved around advertising
has been annihilated by the combination
of Google and Facebook and these
institutions are in some measure in in
desperation trying to reinvent
themselves for the Internet age and
everybody's in pursuit of clickbait even
the grey lady even the most illustrious
of newspapers and I think that's one
explanation the other explanation is
that an institution like the New York
Times has its own University like
character behaves a little bit like
University but the most self-important
newspapers if you go to them are rather
like colleges it's also true of the
Financial Times which is a like a kind
of Cambridge College that sort of ended
up by mistake in London and so they have
some of the same dynamics as as
universities and I think that's
especially true of the New York Times
it's also true of the BBC incidentally
so institutions like The Times and the
BBC think of themselves as being liberal
bastions but for them liberalism is
truth it's the same problem that Harvard
has if you if your motto is Veritas
but you translate that into liberalism
then by definition conservatism must be
untruth and so I think there's a
tendency and it's there in the New York
Times periodically to lash out against
anyone like Jordan Peterson who dissents
from liberal orthodoxy remember part of
what we're dealing here with is a kind
of quasi religious phenomenon the dogmas
of the left have become more and more
religious in their quality as they have
been unmoored from that fundamental
economic rationality which was at the
heart of Marxism when that all went down
in flames in 1989 the left decamp to the
realm of culture and as it did that it
increasingly took on the form of a cult
let me illustrate what I mean yeah cults
define themselves partly by a belief in
a lot of things that are slightly weird
in order to be in a cult you have to
have some weird beliefs and one good
example of a weird belief is that
sexuality is entirely constructed
socially and is not biologically rooted
and you can actually have any gender you
like and there are actually multiple
genders
now that's absurd yeah but to believe it
has become a kind of test yeah of your
yeah of the doxy and and one sees this
at meetings in academia in which people
introduce themselves by name and by
their preferred pronouns now when this
first happened to me my immediate
reaction was introduce myself and say
that my preferred pronouns were eat yes
I restrained myself because I realized
that my sense of humor forged as it was
in Scotland in their 1970s is now almost
entirely politically incorrect and
anything that I consider funny will get
me into trouble
but that has gone on in the media too
and the other thing that's happened is
that the polarization which
characterizes a networked society is now
very visibly there yeah in the realm of
newspapers and cable television one
thing that we all got wrong about the
internet because we hadn't really
thought much about network science was
that we just assumed that if everybody
was connected
everything would be awesome that was the
kind of mantra of Silicon Valley for
about 20 years but no network science
tells you that if you build a social
network even quite a small one there
will be something called homophony
because birds of a feather flock
together I'll bet you already that the
intellectual dark web has two clusters
that are somewhat separate from one
another I sense it happening right now
immediately and that's what happened in
the media so as society became more
polarized politically so too did the
media I think that's Ihnen
that is one of the defining
characteristics of our age the the
polarization or if you like self
segregation that we see online is
translated into almost every realm of
life
can there be any positives out of that
out of that self selection into finding
groups that you're more in common with
that for at least for a certain period
of time there's some goodness there
because you can really sort of get into
your ideas enough to maybe leave the
group then and take those ideas out I
think if you are in whatever you want to
call it the echo chamber or the filter
bubble if you are in a cluster that cuts
you off from contrary ideas you're lost
yeah what was fun about being in a
network of right-leaning undergraduates
in early 1980s Oxford was the world were
in constant combat with the left-leaning
Marxists they were still real Marxists
then and we were far from cutoff
constantly engaging with them and the
soggies Social Democrats in in the
middle and that was what made it
interesting what I see happening in the
networked age is that people can retreat
into a realm of confirmation bias where
they hear only things that are similar
to the things they liked yesterday and
the algorithms are the key here where
you are whether it's YouTube or or on
Facebook or on Twitter you are
essentially going to be fed more of what
you already liked that's deeply
intellectually unhealthy just as a
university cannot be a university if
everybody agrees about first ideological
principles because how can you have
critical thinking in that environment so
it's unhealthy for an
intellectual network to be autarkic so
the one thing the international dark web
must not do is cut itself off from other
networks including the ones that hate us
and we have to be in an argument and we
have to have our minds constantly open
to the possibility that we're wrong
about some things and that's what I see
more or less disappearing from public
life I recognize this at one time when I
was in mortal combat with Paul Krugman
the economists termed journalists and
realized that Koopman could never admit
that he'd ever been wrong and when it
was obvious that he had been because he
his part of his raison d'etre was always
being right about everything did you
happen to see the day that the article
came out the original intellectual dark
web article by Barry the David that came
out that Paul Krugman tweeted it and he
tweeted this thing about how we're all
so oppressed you know just mocking
everybody basically and then a bunch of
us responded to him and I of course
retweeted it and invited him on the show
I said I'd be happy to discuss this you
and it gets a couple thousand retweets
but of course no response like and that
you're right that's what we have to make
sure we don't become but I think there's
a there's a human trait that would sort
of make you want to retreat because it's
exhausting it's having your motives
attack than your humanity attack then
lies and smears and all the things that
I don't see anyone on this side doing I
don't and that's it's an exhausting
fight because we're fighting two
different battles yes I suppose in a
symmetrical war at the moment in the
sense that we haven't recognized that in
the culture war the only thing that
works is reputational destruction I
think we we are guaranteed sleepless
nights remember there's also the
phenomenon of guilty until proved
innocence which is insidious
and means that if the reputational hit
is bad enough there may be no there may
be no recovery for that I was very
struck by the speed with which
reputations were destroyed in the the
me2 movements most virulent phase and
characteristic feature of the process
seemed to be that that men were
essentially guilty until proved innocent
and crimes were conflated with quite
clearly non criminal behavior in ways
that were deeply troubling to my eyes
the false accusation is of course the
the ultimate nightmare of anybody in
this world at this time because if
you're falsely accused well your
reputation can be gone in 24 hours and
that bat has introduced into our lives
something that hasn't really existed
since medieval times the feeling that we
are at the mercy of a wheel of fortune
that can arbitrarily turn against us and
dashes overturn us I think this makes
the culture war a deeply troubling thing
to be a part of and milk most sensible
normal people say God I want a quiet
life get me out of here
and never involve me in any of this
get me off Twitter get me off Facebook
never let my name appear in the New York
Times never let me appear on on a show
like this because it's just too
dangerous I only need to say one thing
that can be taken out of context and
represented as heresy or hate speech as
heresy is now called caress what we now
call heresy and I will be subjected to
potentially weeks of vilification and
maybe worse maybe the vilification will
actually lead me to lose my job
people are right to be fearful of that
yeah well it's one of the things that
that Eric who I mentioned before who we
are dinner with and and just to
illustrate this I'm sure you don't even
want me to say this but just to
illustrate the the level of what we're
talking about we had a private dinner in
a home with Eric and his wife and and
ayaan and you and me and my husband and
then we had there were security guards
out outside so you're not you're not
just saying this stuff like this is this
is real stuff but what Eric is said to
me is that
it's exactly what you're saying that
there's a bravery element here that I
don't even consider I don't consider
myself I don't know what I'm just doing
what I think is right that that really
is the truth but but I want to ask you
about that so so for you for I on it's
not just academic where do you think the
bravery comes in for you I cuz I can
tell there's nothing that I could
possibly ask you here that you wouldn't
give me the clearest honest answer and
and that isn't always how it is with
everybody obviously as an interviewer
but where do you think that comes from
candor has always been one of my
greatest weaknesses and I think I was
probably brought up in a rather
combative family in a rather combatted
part of the world I grew up in in
Glasgow in the West of Scotland and to a
physician and a physics that's right my
mother was a physics teacher my father
was a doctor
yeah and they were the first in their
families to go to university my
grandfather's had served in the world
wars Scots have a self image of
themselves as being courageous the
Scottish regiments were famous I wrote
about this in my one of my earliest
books the pizzi of war were famously the
sharp end of of the British military we
marched towards the sound of gunfire
bagpipes playing that's the self-image
that a small Scottish boy growing up in
the nineteen sixties and seventies was
encouraged to have I remember vividly
the day that 9/11 happened I was sitting
in Oxford where I was then teaching but
planning I'd planned and was intending
to fly to New York very shortly to give
a lecture on 9/12
hmm at New York University indeed I was
booked into a hotel very close to the
World Trade Center and my response when
I saw the attacks was somewhat
bloody-minded my response was very
shortly afterwards to resign my post at
Oxford and go to New York University and
I taught there for two years in a I
suppose
a mood of defiance that the attempt to
terrorize would not terrorize me when I
met I on nine more than nine years ago
now it never crossed my mind as I fell
in love with her which happened very
fast that this implied some meaningful
threat to my person even when the FBI
came to tell me that there had been a
threat against me something that I'd
seen them do to a Arnim more than one
occasion I never gave it a second
thought
because obviously my calling different
from my grandfather's who were called to
fight in real Wars my more much more
manageable calling is to is to protect
her because she's one of the great
heroines of our time an extraordinary
courageous woman who's been through a
hell of a lot and who has never shirked
from saying what she believes is wrong
with modern Islam so it it is second
nature to me to be there with her in
that in that fight in that war that's
what it turns out to beat my war I
always used to wonder as I was growing
up why is it that my generation isn't
really been called on to fight wars the
way my grandfather's generations were
called on and then it turned up then my
war turned up you briefly mentioned this
earlier when you're talking about ion
and Brandeis but can you explain this
intersection of Islamism and the left
how why this has occurred this confuses
a lot of people this idea of the
oppression Olympics and you know I've
got plenty of theories on this that
we've knocked out but but what do you
think it is that has attracted something
that is completely totalitarian in
control with another thing that's so
completely totally I mean I guess that's
the answer right there but well there
are many unholy alliances in in history
and no doubt many people were gravely
surprised when the Ribbentrop Molotov
pact was announced and the Soviet Union
and Nazi Germany formed an alliance so
we shouldn't be entirely surprised when
seemingly odd bedfellows jump into bed
in the case of the Islamists and the
left I think it's pretty clear to me
that the Islamists are the the leading
partner and the leftists are broadly the
useful idiots because the Islamists have
a strategy it's there in Muslim
Brotherhood and other documents for
expanding their network in the West and
part of the strategy is the kind of
partnership that they have formed on
campuses against against their foes one
way in which this works is that you used
the issue of Israel to forge the pacts
with the left so you get the left's
long-standing animosity towards Zionism
and you essentially say well we entirely
agree with you about that let's let's
have an event about how wicked Israel is
and so that's the gateway drug in to
accepting the next thing is well
headscarves are actually empowering for
women don't you think
and isn't it actually Islamophobia to be
in any way critical of Sharia law so you
play the multiculturalist cultural
relativist card and you again depict any
critics of radical Islam as is as in
fact engaged in some kind of Orientalist
project or essentialist project to other
people always talk about other in
academia Muslims and you blur the
distinction between Islam Islamism and
Muslims as people so this has been going
on for a while and the left has broadly
fallen for us
and to me it's just astonishing I
remember looking at the list of
academics who had who had argued that I
an should not receive an honorary degree
at Brandeis and it included professors
of queer studies female professors of
Gender Studies it's incredible you kind
of feel like saying to these people have
you taken a look at what the Muslim
Brotherhood envisages have you read cut
herbs works do you realize that the
project is the permanent demotion of
women to second-class status and
potentially capital punishment for gays
is that something you are aware of and I
can only conclude that they aren't aware
of it and have been very thoroughly
duped as useful idiots usually are so is
that basically because both of these
movements want power so the useful idiot
part of this is that the Islamists are
really just using the left to attain
power and they're doing it all in the
name of diversity and all of these
things and eventually once that power is
attained then for a lack of a better
expression I mean you basically
decapitate them and then you've got they
did it for you they did the work for you
yes I mean I always used to joke with
ayaan that when we lived in Cambridge it
would be fun if all my enemies and all
her enemies came and protested outside
our house together
yeah because after about 20 minutes
they'd they'd fall on one another and
they would her the most tremendous fight
I do think that power is part of it but
if one looks back at the history of
another intolerant totalitarian ideology
Marxism there's a combination of power
and a kind of idealism one must call it
that in the square and the tower I tell
the story of how the Soviets
successfully penetrated the British
establishment by recruiting spies in
Cambridge and the people they recruited
had leanings to the left there were
inspired partly by revulsion at those
aspects of British imperialism or
British classes
but were in many ways legitimately open
to criticism there was an idealism there
at the beginning of guy Burgesses
involvement in Marxism sympathy with
workers during the time of the Great
Depression but those were the useful
idiots that the Soviets cynically
recruited to be spies who whom they
persuaded to betray their countrymen in
what was the single most successful act
of Russian espionage of them all
recruiting these highly educated people
from an incredibly exclusive network the
Cambridge apostles and the related
network that led to Bloomsbury this was
a brilliant strategy something similar
is going on here because I think there
are a great many naive young people who
are drawn to the rhetoric of social
justice I encounter them often people
who say oh there should be limits on
free speech because I don't want such
and such such and such as feelings to be
heard
they're naive they have a very naive you
somehow there can be a circumscribed
form of free speech in know in which
nobody's feelings get hurt that's not
the pursuit of power that's just naivety
and the people who know how to exploit
that naivety are both people amongst the
Islamists and people amongst the
leftists who are pursuing power but you
can never really get to power without
the useful idiots without the naive
idealists who think that they're going
to build utopia with your help yeah and
I don't have to tell you there usually
ends up in dystopia right so and that's
that's something that it's hard to
persuade people off yeah I keep
reflecting on the curious revival of
Margaret Atwood's The Handmaid's Tale
which is always taken to be a vision of
what happens when right-wing people take
over America yeah and to me the amazing
thing that is almost never observed is
that something very like this has
happened it happened in Iran after 1979
and it happened after the Taliban came
to power in Afghanistan so we don't need
to fantasize about crazy evangelical
fascists turning
into baby machines this has already
happened but it was done by Islamists it
was done by people pursuing an extreme
version of Sharia and yet almost nobody
who enthuses about Margaret Atwood's
book realizes that it is actually really
quite powerful realization of what a
theocratic Islamist regime does to women
all right so I want to shift gears a
little bit here and we can either I'm
gonna let you choose we can either go
the historical route or we can go the
present route what are you feeling first
I do want to do both I think the key to
apply to stree which is force I've spent
my whole life doing is that you do both
and you can't do one without the other
because no you can have no real insight
about the present without the past so
why don't we talk about the present and
I'll try to show why to understand it
you need history all right very good so
there are a couple things that are
interesting that you've staked out
positions on over the past couple years
we briefly right before we sat down we
talked about Bragg's it for a second so
you originally were for we're against
Bragg's it yeah then you came around for
it now it seems to be in this odd limbo
that I think unfortunately most people
in America don't even understand what's
what's going I don't think most people
in Britain um I'm sure so when I was
reading your position on this at first I
thought well wait a minute as a
conservative and as someone that wants
some autonomy over his country I was
somewhat surprised actually that you
weren't for it originally so can you
explain your original position and then
how you changed on that there were two
reasons why I was on the side of remain
remain in the EU back in 2016 one was
pure personal loyalty to friends David
Cameron was Prime Minister George
Osborne was Chancellor of the Exchequer
and they are friends of mine and I I
felt obliged as a friend to support them
when they decided to stick with the EU
and not to recommend brexit did that
friendship supersede what your feelings
were or was that because you really
trusted because they could get it and
that's swung it okay and I think the
reason that
I was willing to get on board with
romaine was that I found that arguments
of the Briggs Atia is deeply
unconvincing I remember one night
sitting down and reading a lot of stuff
by Daniel Hannan one of the leading
advocates of of leaving and I remember
thinking that this was just
intellectually completely third-class
and unconvincing thus the notion that
Britain would be better off economically
outside the European Union wouldn't have
passed muster as an undergraduate paper
never mind a graduate paper so I felt
that the brexit EAA's case failed
intellectually because they were
claiming implausibly I thought that you
could have a free lunch that you could
leave the European Union and be better
off and that just seemed to me to be
intellectually completely deceitful I
think it would have been harder for me
if they had said honestly this is going
to cost quite a bit but it's worth it
because if we leave then we shall have
the ability to control our borders and
we shall have autonomy at a time when
Europe is pursuing a Federalists course
but that wasn't the argument the
argument was that not the aria because
that we're going to get the money was
the argument I'm going to gather money
that we give to the European Union and
we're gonna build to spend on the
National Health Service cuz we will be
in fact better off and that was a lie
and I'm not good with lies it was a
clever lie it worked
politically and I give credit to Dominic
Cummings for crafting a message that was
appealing both to conservatives and to
labour voters the Conservatives got
immigration control labour voters got
the National Health Service gets the
money so this is brilliant politically
but it was mendacious I think given that
part and so I I opposed the brexit when
it happened what struck me in the
subsequent months was that while I had
been while I had been on the side that
lost
there was a good reason why we lost and
the good reason was that we went around
saying how much it was going to cost and
I think we were right about that I think
ultimately at least some of what the
Treasury said will true will turn out to
be true about the cost but that wasn't
what people cared about mm-hmm and when
you went into pubs as I did in Wales in
England and in Scotland there was a
question to which you could not give an
honest answer without losing the debate
and I'll tell you what that question was
because I was asked it multiple times
you'd make the case about the cost
nobody was interested in the cost they
would say listen Neil about the 1.3
million Muslims the Germans have just
let in to Germany because that had just
happened mm-hmm if the Germans give them
German passports can they come here and
the only honest answers of that question
was yes so immigration was the issue and
I think for a significant number of
people in England and Wales especially
was less so in Scotland where brexit was
defeated the realization was that
Britain had lost control of immigration
the people had been promised net
migration in the tens of thousands in
the 1990s under the Blair government and
they'd ended up with net migration in
the hundreds of thousands they saw the
chaos in Germany they saw the waves of
migration coming not only from Syria but
from all over North Africa and and even
South Asia and they said ah I remember
David Cameron using this phrase get me
out of here and that was that was the
driving motivation for the brexit vote
and I think it was legitimate because I
think that Angela Merkel had made a
catastrophic mistake in throwing open
the gates I think it will have dire
consequences for the future of Germany
and of Europe and I do not blame British
voters for saying forget about the cost
of brexit we really need to get out of
this so I take took the view by the end
of 2016 that you had to
you had to respect the fact that
ordinary people had cut through the crap
of the debate and it got to the heart of
the matter and the heart of the matter
wasn't the cost of brixon which is what
i had i think mistakenly focused on
prior to the referendum what was it like
for you as a public person and you know
some of the rights about this stuff and
puts your opinions out there to have
that realization I think it's very
important if you write regularly if you
are what we call a public intellectual
to be willing to admit that you've been
wrong I think you have to be prepared to
say I was wrong and I think I was wrong
in the sense that what I wish I had done
looking back was I wish I had said to
David Cameron George Osborne in the
spring of 2016 when it was clear that
the Europeans were going to make no
meaningful concession on the immigration
issue when they basically sent an
insulting proposal about what could be
done about migration that was the moment
I should have said to Cameron Osbourne
forget it
yeah you should campaign for brexit if
that's all they're going to offer you if
they're so completely oblivious to the
very real concerns about immigration
then you should campaign for breaks
instead of which we stuck with it and
that was that was David Cameron's great
mistake he should have said at that
moment if that's all you've got
I'm going to recommend breaks it to the
voters and it would have saved him too
so so you think it was just a bad
negotiating ploy that he just didn't use
some leverage to say we're gonna have to
walk away from this there was there was
a moment when he should have walked away
and I should have advised him to walk
away so yeah I think one has to
recognize when one's made a mistake with
such consequences the second thing which
is worth knowing about this is that the
people who then inherited power after
the fall of Cameron at nas born we're
not the people who had campaigned for
and won on writing it was people who've
been on the remain side Theresa May
became Prime Minister I always knew that
would be a disaster I did not have high
regard
for her prior to the referendum the
Daily Mail essentially put her in that
position and also Boris Johnson Michael
Gove and others because they bungled the
leadership contest
so we then ended up with a terrible
combination which was a commitment to
breaks it but its execution in the hands
of people who had been remain errs and I
think the result is the worst of both
worlds because right now we essentially
have the psychological reality of brexit
I think British public to a large extent
has accepted that we are leaving
but the executions are total mess yeah
by invoking article 50 early on the UK
and essentially ceded the the power in
the divorce to the European Union and
the concessions have come one after
another ever since then and we now find
ourselves in the odd predicament that I
think Theresa May is saying that brings
it means you cease to be a voting member
of the European Union but you remain
within the customs union potentially
even within the single market and you
accept all the rules and regulations of
the European Union you just don't have
any power if that's the end game yeah
then it's a disaster so the people that
are trying to stop this now they want to
invoke some some pretty crazy extreme
stuff right I mean there would be some
really very rarely if ever used rules am
i right about this that would actually
allow this to allow the state to occur
well listen I think those games without
getting into all of them I think that
there is a level of complexity in the
discussions now in London that is
bewildering to most ordinary British
people when people start talking about
max FAC and the customs union as a
complex confusing way because I discuss
it with Douglas Murray and he was even a
little confused it's actually not
confusing in the sense that what is
happening is that Theresa May is trying
to get Britain to accept the realities
of belonging to the European customs
union which would preclude Britain
having its own trade policy with our
leaving the European Union's
decision-making body so essentially in
version breaks it is just you have the
responsibilities you just don't have any
power anymore which is definitely not
what the British public was told or and
it was getting in in brexit the the
bigger problem in my mind is is not one
that that we've discussed and that is
that all of this will end in tears to
the point at which Jeremy Corbyn the
most left-wing leader the Labour Party
has ever had in its history becomes
Prime Minister because Theresa May is
leading the country towards this very
unhappy compromise at some point the
people who truly believe in brexit Jacob
Riis MOG for example perhaps Michael
Gove they may decide we can't ultimately
accept this and the government may fall
but the problem is that if the
government Falls then Jeremy Corbyn is
Prime Minister if the government doesn't
fall and we go all the way to the
finishing line with this Theresa May
version of brexit then I think the
conservative will lose the next election
in 2022 and Jeremy Coleman will be Prime
Minister so the worst they are about
Greg's it is in my view that if it is
bungled in this way it will open the
door to a truly leftist government and
that will be far more economically
damaging then anything Briggs it has
done and that's the nightmare scenario
for me and probably socially damaging
and fever zillion other reasons deeply I
should be extremely suspicious of
Coleman and his people they are
committed Marxists they've been on the
wrong side of every issue in my lifetime
with a possible exception of South
African apartheid and I do not trust
them with the keys to 10 Downing Street
because I think that their ultimate
agenda is a truly revolutionary one and
it poses a threat to the fundamental
liberties the traditions of the
Constitution it's a dangerous dangerous
prospect and I'm much more worried about
kolben that about brings it I mean this
is how I feel about what's happening
with our left in America talking about
you you guys are giving us basically the
precursor to this I think one of the
lessons of history and now we can bring
history in is that with populism you you
get two flavors
in a typical backlash that would come
after a financial crisis the political
establishments discredited there's a
backlash against inequality all of the
things that typically follow are
financial crisis but there are two
possibilities
there's the populism of the left which
is the tax the rich solution but the
populism of the right is more potent
because it says it's a bad immigration
it's about globalization it's about free
trade mm-hmm
and so broadly speaking there's a very
good study that shows this after a big
financial crises the populous of the
right do better because they offer a
more plausible story but if they don't
deliver when they generally don't
because quite hard to make immigration
control and tariffs pay it's quite hard
actually to make your constituents
better off with those policies then the
pendulum has a tendency to swing to the
populism of the left and that has
happened in Britain really quickly
because Corbin became popular
very soon after breaks it it's slower
here but the fear must be that if the
Trump experiment goes as wrong as the
vast majority of intellectuals expect it
to the pendulum will swing to the the
left of the Democratic Party and that
scenario seems to me more and more
plausible and I don't think that's a
that's not an appetizing yeah I mean
that vent that's genuinely scary to me
but I want to back up for one second
because the moment that you had that you
said a few times happened in these pubs
when you would go there and people would
say this about 1.3 million Muslims in in
Germany how do you so okay so that if
you were listening to the mainstream
media they would say these people are
all racist that's what they would tell
you they're they're racists and they're
bigots I suspect that's not what you
think of these people although there
probably was a certain amount of people
that are just racist and don't like
people of a different color or a
different culture how do you even have
that conversation because that's what so
much of this is about cuz you I'm sure
would have a pint with these people and
you talk to them and realize that they
weren't racist they were actually just
worried about
their future which is legit but if you
can't have that discussion because every
time you open your mouth they tell you
you're racist well then we know what you
end up with look I would be very strange
if I took a bigoted view on this subject
because I'm an immigrant I'm in fact
about to become an American citizen in a
matter of weeks my wife was a refugee
who got from Somalia originally to the
Netherlands by applying for asylum
mm-hmm and so we would be the last
couple to take a kind of bigoted view on
the immigration issue because where the
grits when I had conversations on this
subject at the time of the brexit
referendum I remember realizing that the
opposition to immigration was not
plausibly a racist because and remember
somebody making the point that he was as
worried about the people from Lithuania
and Poland coming to Britain as he was
about people from Syria and Iraq I and
you probably know that people from
Poland in Lithuania are pretty wise
great so here's the thing what we all
read to recognize is that if immigration
shoots up if it grows from in the case
of Britain 10,000 or 20,000 a year to
200,000 or 300,000 a year perfectly
unprejudiced people will say that's too
much this is going too fast
and that I think was the dominant
argument of course there are people who
are racists in any society but the
striking thing about Britain is actually
that it's not a terribly racist place
did you see many people protesting
against Prince Harry's decision to marry
an American of mixed-race I was there a
couple days before the bull the very
example were huge crowds this match is
extraordinary
pila with ordinary people so I think
it's hard to argue that racism played
any meaningful part the white
supremacist elements in Britain is
really is really very insignificant and
actually one of the ways in which the
British like to define themselves is as
being tolerant memories of the war of
not entirely faded even as the wartime
generation gradually disappears from the
scene what was the war against Germany
about it was a war against the ultimate
racist state what hurt Jeremy Corbyn the
most in the last three or four months
the evidence that there are anti-semitic
elements within his faction of the
Labour left that hurts him and it's
important that that argument keep being
made because it has real truth to it and
I think all the way people think that's
not good so I think this is not really
about racism it's not about bigotry it's
about how rapidly should immigration
occur how large should flows be across
borders and the lesson of history is
that if you allow a real surge in
immigration there will be a populist
backlash against what happened in the
United States in the late 19th century
at the peak in the 1880s the
foreign-born percentage of the
population in the US was about 14% it
had gone up from relatively low levels
about 14% the same thing has happened in
our time it was down I think below 7% in
the mid 20th century and the period
after World War Two immigrants were a
relatively small proportion late
foreign-born citizens of a pretty small
portion of the US population and then
from the 1980s onwards the proportion
surged and the character of the
immigrants changed that the places that
they came from changed and these changes
are bound to elicit a reaction it always
happens and it's not enough for people
in the liberal elites who by and large
don't live in areas where immigrants
come to say what a terrible deplorable
bunch of chauvinists you are for not
wanting for not wanting more immigrants
that's simply but simply historically
and the other thing that's stupid about
this in the United States is the people
on the Left who want to legitimize
illegal immigration now I think for many
people who were attracted to Trump the
issue was the illegal quality of the
immigration the rule of law is a big
deal now in the english-speaking world
and people don't like to hear anything
that simply says amnesty for lawbreakers
if you're a law-abiding citizen and
you're suddenly told well yeah the law
applies to you but there are these other
people it's not going to apply to you
then your natural reaction is screw this
that's why I thought one of his best
lines he doesn't use it as much anymore
but during the campaign we're either a
country or were not I thought was a
really effective line
you either have laws or you don't I mean
that in essence is the truth so let's
shift to Trump a little bit here I think
that we're kind of in a similar spot
with him which is that it's better than
the alternative that that's certainly
how I feel at this point that all of the
forces that we've spent the last hour
plus talking about would be that much
more emboldened against free thought and
all and free expression and open inquiry
and all the things that we care about
and an historical fact and and
everything else if he wasn't president
right now I am deeply ambivalent about
all of this I think it's it's very very
hard to say a good word about the
personality of Donald Trump I'm with you
it was a reason that I found it
impossible to support him in 2016 I
think one has to acknowledge that he has
used inflammatory language on the issues
we've talked about immigration that he
has a record of lying which is even by
the standards of American presidents
pretty remarkable and so
familiy a list of things about Donald
Trump that most of my friends find
objectionable is kind of hard for me to
to dismiss mm-hmm but I said I'm bivolo
for a reason on the other hand number
one what if he'd lost I said this to Sam
Harris a few weeks ago let's run the
counterfactual this is what historians
should do let's imagine an alternative
history if don't firm had lost the
election by let's say the same narrow
margin that he won it how would all
those people who voted for him have felt
and how would they have behaved so my
mind the election of Donald Trump is a
cathartic moment for those people so
despised by the liberal elites that they
could refer to them as deplorable
the people who voted for Donald Trump
are not by and large racists are not by
and large anything like Donald Trump is
personally what attracted them to Trump
were two things which as with the brexit
campaign were legitimate number one they
were attracted to Trump's policy
positions on trade on immigration on
Islam and on the somewhat a corrupt
liberal elite that had been running the
country for the previous eight years so
I think they were attracted to Trump's
policy positions but they were also
attracted to his cultural position and I
think about half of American populism is
cultural what attracted the friends I
have who supported Trump to Trump was
his fundamental shift in language away
from the politically correct talking
points of the political class
Republicans and Democrats alike to a
domotic
normal way of speaking such as you would
hear in the typical American are more or
less anywhere in the country except
Cambridge Massachusetts Stanford
California and the rest now I I remember
thinking on the eve of the election if
you'd line up all the people who are
going to
for her and you line up all the people
who are going to vote for him which line
would you rather be in remember at that
point I'm not a citizen I don't know it
and I thought that's easy I'm with the
people who are so pissed with the
political establishment that they're
ready to take a chance on this guy
because they see no other way to shake
things up the way my friend Gerry Blake
put it to me
ex-marine core ex-nypd never when a
college helps take care of my wife
security Gerry said to me early 2016
two things that stuck in my mind first
he told me John was gonna win but then
he said the two reasons why he supported
from number one he tells it like it is
number two he's gonna shake things up by
he tells it like it is Gerry did not
mean he is always truthful what he meant
was he talks like me by shaking things
up Gerry meant we have to do something
because this system as it stands is not
in my interests it's not in my interest
economically because it seems to favor
China over the United States Mexicans
over native-born Americans the rich 1%
over me the median household but he's
also it's also about this cultural
reaction against the multiculturalism
that has become the orthodoxy of the
liberal left so for all my reservations
about Trump I completely got why people
voted for him and I think their reaction
had he lost would have been toxic I
don't think they would have accepted the
legitimacy of the results I think they
would have bought the story Trump would
have told them that the election had
been rigged and I think we would have
had a poisoned body politic from day one
of a binson presidency if it all ends
oddly though were having that right now
just in the reverse all right it would
have been worse but we're having a left
that's not accepting the legitimacy of
the election and I think it would have
been worse yeah I think it would have
been worse
and I think and this is another part of
the story
but for Jerian his and his many many
fellow Americans who voted Trump this
has always been a gamble and they've
always had a sense that it could go
wrong you know when you shake things up
but sometimes they break mm-hmm and I
sense that if it all ends in Fiasco
which I guess the vast majority of
public intellectuals expect and some
combination of Watergate and other
scandals I think Jerry and his and his
fellow American Trump supporters all say
well we gave it a try give it a try and
I think that's that's one possible
scenario the other reason that I I'm
ambivalent about Trump is that for all
his flaws in some ways he's doing a
better job on foreign policy than his
predecessor did because Trump has this
superpower that most intellectuals can
understand he has an unerring instinct
for the weakness of the counterparty
it's a kind of almost animal instinct
but somehow Donald Trump can tell when
the other side is weak he could see it
in Jeb Bush you could see it Marco Rubio
could see it in Hillary Clinton and now
I think he sees it in the Europeans he
sees an Angela Merkel you don't pay
enough for your defense what if I walk
out on NATO yeah Kim jong-un he sees it
in she's in pink he sees it in the in
the Supreme Leader in her arm
so my ambivalence is partly by sympathy
for Trump supporters Mike my fundamental
sense of why they voted for him but it's
also that in some ways this disruption
has its plus site in the way that it's
repositioning the United States I mean I
to me it's given oxygen to everything
that we've talked about here and that
doesn't that doesn't discount all of the
legitimate concerns that you look the
big concern for me as I mentioned before
is that the pendulum swings the other
way if this all ends in tears all of
those who defended it even if they
defended it half-heartedly like me will
be discredited
mm-hmm and the damage will be
irreparable for conservatives and
populist Szalai the left will be
empowered and they will spend the rest
of our lives
telling us that we were
adjusts for the worst president and
that's that's not a scenario that you
can discount likely for a time I think
it was exhilarating our freely admit
that for me one of the most satisfying
aspects of Trump's victory was that all
the people I most disliked in this
contract we're in a state of hysteria
and shock for weeks and I remember
saying that I aren't you know it can't
be all bad if the people I really can't
stand are in this state but you have to
I think with history and mind be
conscious of the dangers of the fact
that this could end yeah so badly that
it does irreparable damage and and the
worst damage of all will be if it
propels the left of the Democratic Party
into power and that you can't rule out
you can't really the worst thing about
studying history is that it makes you
aware of how undetermined istic the
historical process is that there is
always more than one future there's the
future of triumph there's the future of
tragedy and there's this kind of other
future in the middle which is a little
bit of both and that's really why the
historical moment is bad for restful
sleep one wakes up in the morning and
I'm sure you have the same feeling
wondering what alert will be on your
phone and what message will be on your
phone
well the alerts say Wars broken out will
the alert say our palace coup and will
the message say your reputation has just
been been destroyed by some accusation
or other so one wakes up in a state of
anxiety in the United States of 2018 and
that is a reality so that I think is
inherent in both the culture war that
we've spoken about and the Trump
presidency which is in some measure a
backlash against that that culture war
we're gonna leave it at that but I am
going to demand that you come back I
don't think I've ever demanded that I
guess but I'm legitimate
demanding that you come back because
next time I want to do I want to just do
all history and yeah we try to even
barely jump into I won't have any prior
stuff and Churchill and I okay I'm
demanding it will you accept my demand I
accept all right it took a long time to
get here but but considering we're both
two guys just off planes today you're
you're like 37 hours out of whack the
jet lag and who knows what things we
said will be taken out of context on
Twitter well I sincerely hope everything
because the whole thing goes this has
truly truly been an absolute pleasure
and thank you for doing this and send my
best of course
Ayana sure will and for more on Neil you
can follow him on the Twitter although
you don't fight with people that much on
Twitter which means you have strong
moral character I decided the jungle
warfare was not the way to go he's a
wise man and it's @n f e RG u s
[Music]
you